the parents being called all sorts of
names in the battle over education
democratic virginia gubernatorial
candidate terry mcauliffe making another
controversial claim
i am sick of them talking about these
issues of critical race theory we do not
teach critical race theory here in
virginia it has never been taught it is
a racist dog whistle it is pitting
parents against parents parents against
teachers and they're using our children
as political pawns and it has got to
stop
so while mcauliffe denies that crt is
being taught in schools take a look at
these headlines virginia's department of
education promoting a book that says
quote teachers must embrace theories
such as critical race theory a slide
presentation from fairfax county public
schools reportedly instructed social
studies teachers that quote critical
race theory is a frame for their work
and christopher ruffo who has been
leading the way on this issue says terry
mcauliffe just not telling the truth
mcauliffe's idea that it's not taught in
virginia schools is verifiably false
we have records including actual
contractor seats from loudoun county
virginia they actually are paying 625 an
hour for consulting that specifically uh
references critical race theory by name
all right katie this is turning out to
be a huge deal where we live in virginia
and the governor's race is underway i
mean whether terry mcauliffe wants it to
be or not it is
terry mcauliffe keeps insulting the very
people he needs to vote for him the
people who've 10 000 of them have taken
their kids out of out of schools in
loudoun county alone fairfax county um
the fact is that they are teaching
critical race theory he doesn't want to
acknowledge it but but telling people
it's just not happening
you know it makes them feel pretty
insulted fairfax county paid ibrahim x
kendy who is a racist himself 20 000
to give a speech for an hour to school
administrators and to
teachers last summer
they backed that up when it came to
light in public documents that they had
paid in that much money saying it was
essential to how they learned to teach
children it's not just the issue of
critical race theory either it's about
pornographic books being in these
libraries for young children parents
reading them out loud and embarrassing
school boards over it and they they went
well what do you think the parents are
doing um they're terry mcauliffe also
keeps smearing parents by saying this is
a racist dog whistle to bring up
critical race theory there are parents
in loudoun county and fairfax county
from all different backgrounds including
a woman who grew up in mao's china who
have come up to these meetings to say we
don't want this in our schools it is not
just white parents who are living in
suburbia going to these school board
meetings and finally i would say it is
not a good look for the loudoun county
school board to be calling the sheriff's
department and acting like these people
are domestic terrorists asking for all
these insane security measures simply to
keep them out from speaking to them when
they are taxpayer-funded and have the
right to be there and so you know terry
mcauliffe thinks that insulting them is
the way out of this when he should
really be listening to them and their
concerns well he does need their votes
whoever's going to win there has got to
get those votes now i thought this was
interesting in minnesota there's a
school board that says if you're going
to come up and speak you have to list
your name you have to say it out loud
late name and your address or jesse you
won't be allowed to speak
yeah so they're basically asking parents
to dox themselves
wow that's pretty scary and it's
uncalled for there's no need for that
but mcauliffe i don't know if he's dumb
or lying or doesn't know what crt is he
gave birth to crt in 2015 it started in
virginia under his tutelage shannon
bream
and and now it's taken off like a rocket
ship katie's right they have all kinds
of contracts for all kinds of wackos and
institutions one of them got 2.4 million
and that happened to be the son-in-law
of merrick garland and it's not just
that i've read all the texts in the
language in that commonwealth of
virginia it's talking about white
students need to apologize and
acknowledge their white privilege makes
black students ashamed of their heritage
it's really sick stuff they are teaching
racism in virginia and if parents oppose
that the governor says you're a racist
that's where we are in 2021 but i think
the wheels have fallen off the mcauliffe
campaign he seems defensive no one's
showing up to his events and now he's
just criticizing voters that he needs 20
bucks he wins you think 20.
this is a blue state that biden won by
double digits and now it's a dead heat
because of this issue it wins the win 20
bucks hey 20. gonna take it right here
20
20. let's go
let's go next week we're going to check
back in on that okay in the meantime
geraldo um parents do have a lot of
different concerns katie talked about
this uh and there's a big ad that has to
do with this about books and things that
are full of vulgarity and violence that
when they've gone to read them before
the school board the school brand's been
like well you can't use that language
here like actually shut them down uh but
parents say listen we should know what's
involved with our kids and we should
have to say all true all true but for
decades i've heard this argument about
uh you know it was always about sex in
the old days you know don't teach you
know uh over word or explicit sex to the
kids that are too young i i think that i
want to be a moderate here i think both
sides are right i think it and and i
also think that everybody is now on
notice everybody's noticed the the
teachers unions they have to getting
burnt and the national school board
association and all the after getting
burnt and these embarrassing headlines
about uh you know lying about the what
they what they're doing what their
instincts are what their you know
critical race there is i think that they
on the one hand get it and on the other
hand the parents and and katie i think
you're almost always right except when i
look at those those school board
meetings i see a sea of white faces
nothing that there's nothing wrong with
that you're not looking very well maybe
it may be more attractive maybe i'm
missing the odd puerto rican hero or
there but i just american parents but i
i think what my point is that i think
that the parents are on notice that that
that egregious over aggressive that
is is over the top and i think the
teachers are also on the next right
never over
apparently some yelling and screaming is
okay but other yelling and screaming
they're burning things down
okay not okay yeah in fact uh you know
mccullough called it a dog whistle uh
this the parents concern
there are actual real racist dog
whistles if you think black people can't
get an id
that's a that's a dog whistle if you
think rioting in looting is acceptable
behavior because they're black that is a
racist dog whistle i used to think
there's nothing more racist than a low
bar but the dems introduced no bar and
that's what we're seeing right now
that's why there's there were so few
prosecutions after all of these riots
look to them the left everything is
racist except actual racism you could
blanket all whites as oppressive and
that's not racism that's considered
education but if you call it out
mcauliffe calls you a racist but i think
what i think it was your point jesse i
can't remember uh i think it's over
generally it's over they have killed the
accusation of racism once and for all
you keep calling people racist it
doesn't mean anything anymore they beat
it to death and people are now not
afraid people used to be afraid of being
called racist because it is it's like
being called a pedophile but they did it
so much it's like
you know what i'm going to challenge you
i am not a racist and that's what
parents are doing i think i think the
left is in trouble if they don't come up
with new ideas they're sunk well see now
i'm a hopeful libertarian
sounds very hopeful to me in the blink
of an eye you guys have brought him up